FIRST EVER START AGAINST
CHICAGO, AGAINST 37 THE
VETERANMURPHY.
AND A HOLDING CALL, AND I ASSUME
IT'S AGAIN
AND NOW AROUND TO THE NEAR SIDE
FOR PERRRRND AS WE WERE FOCUSED
ONER 23RDRD.
>> John: YEAH, THAT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE AS NOW FAULK
HERE'S A LONG PAT FOR KOSTIN.
HE HAS A HALFHE
CREASE YOU HAVE TO LOVE THAT IN
A STRAIGHT LINE.
DON'T PULL UP IN
>> Darren:BOUT THAT IN OUR
OPEN.
THAT'S HIS 48TH OF THE SEASON
AND THISCABE, AND THEN AHEAD FO?
NEW JERSEY CAME IN AND DID WHAT
THEY HAD TO 2-0.
KUBALIN, AND
THE FACE-OFF BY O'REILLY LOOKED
LIKE HEITH SIX
GOALS AND 14 POINTS DARREN HISK.
AND THEN  IT TO HIM BUT
TARASENKO WAS ACTUALLY SKATING
FORWARD.
SO THE BLACKHAWKS WERE ABLE TO
THERE, NOW FOR THOMAS ACROSS TO
PARAYKO.
BACK TO KRUG, THE DRIVE, HEF WE.
ARD BUT THE
HAWKS GET IT OUT.
SAAD COMES IN THERE.
HERE'S HAGEL TRYING TO MAKE A  M
AND
I'M NOT HELPING ANYBODY OUT
TECHNIQUE AND STYLE AND THE
HOCKEY SENSE OF THE GOALTENDER
MARC-ANDRE FLEURY.
OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN SEE PUCK TRIC
CENTER, MARC-ANDRE FLEURY,
NO PLAY TO BE MADE THERE TO THE
AT THE WAY BUCHNEVICH CAME IN.S
CENTER.
HERE COMES MIKKOLA STEPPING UP.
AND NOW PERRON AGAIN.
OF SHRINKING THE OFFENSIVE ZONE,
NOT SAGGING BACKKBLOUSE GOALS F
BY KYROU LOOKING FOR O'REILLY.
STEERED BACK MIDDLE
OF THE ICE AND WHAT A PASS THAT
IS BY